all you convicted fellows come out and
vote today mike spent
20 years in jail for drugs offenses in
florida
he lost his freedom and his right to
vote
until now this is the first time you can
vote
what does that mean to you oh
it's like um have a new life it really
means a lot to me because i'm a
convicted felon and it took a very very
long time for me to get my rights back
mike's one of thousands who benefited
from a change in law in florida
but many missed out in 2018 more than a
million former offenders got the right
to vote in a massive extension of
democracy
but a year later campaigners say the
majority effectively lost it again
after republican politicians here ruled
all fines had to be paid off
before voter rights were restored
hello hi my name is linda and i want to
give you some information about voting
florida's black and poor communities
have been hardest
hit by the change in rules linda's one
of hundreds of volunteers
trying to get people to the polls are
you a convicted felon
yes ma'am but many like thomas have
given up
i feel like at the end of the day our
vote really doesn't matter
we have a lot a lot of citizens have
lost their votes here
if thousands of former convicts voted it
could swing the results here
you got puerto ricans you got mexicans
you got the haitian people and the
blacks
and some whites has been affected by
uh their rights because they've been in
prison and they don't know their rights
hey how you doing how are y'all doing
let me just give you so you know where
to go vote it
republicans who support the law say the
fines are part of the sentence
so must be paid before voting rights are
restored
but without jobs or homes many can't
afford them
and when you get out you thought your
debt society's been paid but
i thought mine was all done they hit me
with like 3 800
in court costs campaigners believe it's
a deliberate tactic
to keep people away from the polls
overwhelmingly
black communities tend to vote democrat
do you think there's a bit of
voter suppression in this decision for
the state of florida i would definitely
say yes
simply because it's been said over time
that individuals especially african
americans
they are going to vote democrats
especially if they get their voting
rights back
these activists with celebrities like
lebron james are trying to pay off the
debts
but times run out
at least three-quarters of a million of
florida's former felons
will miss out on this election siobhan
robbins
sky news florida